president Trump CIA director is calling
WikiLeaks a hostile intelligence service
director Mike Pompeo accused WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange of working with
Russia to leak stolen information from
Hillary Clinton campaign officials
WikiLeaks responded on Twitter saying
pompeo himself highlighted one of those
leaks last year and called it proof that
the Democrats primary race was fixed
Nancy Cordes is in Washington with the
cia's new vow to take action Nancy good
morning good morning the CIA director
doesn't speak publicly very often so it
was striking that he chose to make
WikiLeaks the focus of this speech she
called the founder Julian Assange a
narcissist and a coward who has done
irreparable damage to US national
security and he warned that Assange is
assuming incorrectly that the First
Amendment will protect him from
punishment Julian Assange eNOS kinder
not the slightest bit interest in
improving civil liberties or enhancing
personal freedom in his first public
address as CIA director Mike Pompeo came
out swinging at WikiLeaks and its
founder Julian Assange it's time to call
out WikiLeaks for what it really is a
non-state hostile intelligence service
often abetted by state actors like
Russia the former congressman accused
WikiLeaks of working directly with
Russian intelligence to release e-mails
stolen from the Democratic Party and the
Clinton campaign our intelligence
community determined that Russian
military intelligence the GRU had used
WikiLeaks to release data of us victims
that the GRU had obtained through cyber
operations against the Democratic
National Committee in a rare public
appearance last month the sánge
announced the release of thousands of
sensitive CIA documents the Central
Intelligence Agency lost control of its
entire cyber weapons arsenal the elusive
Asajj insisted he isn't anti-us or
pro-russia on Russia and China we have
probably hundreds of thousands of things
most of them are critical as a candidate
president Trump was a fan of WikiLeaks
WikiLeaks I love WikiLeaks because many
of the disclosures hurt his opponent
Hillary Clinton this
WikiLeaks is like a treasure trove the
White House was briefed on pompeo speech
in advance pompeo said the u.s. is going
to go after non-state actors like
WikiLeaks more aggressively than it has
before though he acknowledged it isn't
easy to take down foreign operators
relying on a shadowy web of
sophisticated hackers Charlie Nancy
thanks